covet hospitalizations have increased
and we're told at a faster pace in clark
county there's been a 15.5 percent
increase over the past week with 432
more people in the hospital this surge
part of the reason clark county remains
at a high community level and speaking
of covid for most of us i think it's
safe to say normal life is back after
the pandemic but the coronavirus still
hasn't gone away yes we've been
reporting many americans getting co-ed
for a second third even a fourth time as
john lingler reports a troubling new
study reveals the dangers of
re-infection the latest numbers from
nevada health officials show coronavirus
cases and deaths are staying relatively
low an average of 870 cases and two
deaths every day but there is new
research and it suggests new variants
and repeat cases could be more dangerous
i don't see any reason to court that
i'm not interested in going through that
aging is you know difficult enough lois
tucker feels fortunate she's never
tested positive for coronavirus however
her brother has and he's still battling
through long coveted symptoms shortness
of breath brain fog and the thing that
bothers him the most is
his legs and his feet
just like a tingling numb
strange feeling in his feet
doctors have been trying to learn more
about the cause of long-term covit but a
new study out of the veterans affairs
health system finds some health risks of
re-infection patients who have had two
or more cases of covet had more than
twice the risk of dying they are also
three times more likely to be
hospitalized within six months of their
last infection so that's the problem
with this damn thing it's just like
every time you think you figured out and
you kind of understand
the dimensions of it it comes up with a
new curveball and it's like okay that
thing i used to think two months ago no
longer works dr bob wachter is the chief
of medicine at uc san francisco he says
some of the health problems include
strokes and heart attacks while dr
wachter doesn't think mask mandates are
necessary again he is worried about a
new ba5 coronavirus subvariant it's
spreading rapidly he says vaccination
and prior infection don't work as well
as they used to in preventing new cases
there's a ton of cases around and and a
variant that's far more infectious than
ever before
dr walker says those who still need to
get the booster get the booster shot of
the coronavirus vaccine it may not stop
you from catching coronavirus but he
does say it's effective in preventing
severe disease john lagler live local
now